[Aplausos]
cuántos de vosotros habéis pensado
recientemente en un cambio de carrera o
en emprender algo nuevo haber manos
algunos por aquí
vale pensar en este cambio en esta
transición entre mad men y big band'
jerry mad men me imagino que la uvic ice
es una serie que habla de los años de la
publicidad whisky cigarrito la
publicidad tradicional imaginaros un
salto a big band thierry con sheldon
este trayecto es el que yo he recorrido
en los últimos años
y a través de ese trayecto he podido
incorporar algunos aprendizajes y que
luego de reflexionar lo a través de los
años me doy cuenta que son principios
que tienen que ver también con la
mentalidad de emprendimiento
todos los que estamos aquí somos una
startup somos una startup como
individuos como personas porque porque
tenemos un proyecto tenemos unos planes
tenemos unas ideas y precisamente esa
mentalidad de emprendimiento es la que
yo vengo a inspirar hoy con estos
principios que yo ido aprendiendo en
esta transición les voy a contar tres
principios el primero de ellos tiene que
ver con el aceptar y hasta disfrutar el
no saber
y qué difícil porque estamos entrenados
a saber a controlar y cuando no sabemos
y no controlamos lo disimulamos
estamos acostumbrados a eso a la
capacidad de intentar controlarlo todo
vale sin embargo este principio tiene
que ver con el aceptar
esa capacidad de no saber cómo una
puerta al descubrimiento en el mundo de
la tecnología el no saber es un espacio
para la innovación es un espacio para la
creatividad de hecho puede ser una
oportunidad porque es un espacio que se
puede llenar es un espacio que se puede
llenar de ideas de innovación de cosas
nuevas
entonces esa transición de el no saber
y poderlo abrazar ha sido una de las
experiencias más importantes y parte de
eso tiene que ver con la recuperación de
la capacidad del asombro
hemos perdido esa capacidad también
hemos sido entrenados a que las cosas
nos parezcan normales aquí estamos más
de 1000 personas reunidas
en un evento interesadas en lo mismo y
nos asombroso
es asombroso pero al mismo tiempo hemos
perdido esa capacidad porque asombrarse
parece que también es como de inexpertos
de novatos no yo lo sé todo para que me
voy a asombrar y esta recuperación de la
capacidad de asombro es un principio
fundamental de esta mentalidad de
emprendimiento ha sido además parte
fundamental del desarrollo de la
humanidad si lo veis los inventos y los
grandes descubrimientos han nacido del
asombro y os voy a contar una historia
que me sucedió en mis primeros años en
tecnología iba a san francisco a un
viaje y junto a mí se sienta un
ingeniero un desarrollador de los que
trabajaba en mi equipo y el avión está
en la pista y despega
normal
y este chico se revuelve en su asiento y
me dice es que no puedo creer que este
avión despegue y claro yo en un momento
me ha asustado porque dije que sabe el
que yo no sé
y era su asombro por que el avión
despegara y me hizo pensar que doy
tantas cosas por hecho
el mismo platón decía que la capacidad
de maravilla es lo que hace que un
filósofo sea filósofo y sí y si venimos
a nuestros días daniel kahneman que lo
conoceréis premio nobel de economía dice
que esta capacidad de maravilla es parte
de la esencia de nuestra vida mental
entonces yo os invito a pensar cuando
fue la última vez que os habéis
asombrado
cuántas veces dais las cosas que veis
por hecho por normales cuando la magia
nos rodea permanentemente
primer principio pasar de aceptar el no
saber y recuperar el asombro
el segundo principio tiene que ver
con ver a la data como amiga de la
imaginación y pareciera en dos mundos
contrarios data imaginación
eso fue un gran aprendizaje en realidad
nos enamoramos de nuestras ideas las
abrazamos les damos un valor increíble y
nos cuesta soltarlas y nos cuesta
también abrirlas a la realidad y que los
datos que están allí las puedan mejorar
o las puedan porque no quiso modificar
estamos en un momento en el que la
tecnología nos arroja muchísima
información permanentemente tenemos la
capacidad de medir todo y esa
información es procesada esa información
es analizada y esa información nos
permite identificar patrones hay hay un
mundo enorme de descubrimiento de
fascinación de imaginación
y parte de este aprendizaje tiene que
ver con el cambio de percepción ante ese
mundo de la data
parte de lo que hice para entender esto
fue entrevistar a ingenieros a
desarrolladores y ver cómo piensan cómo
crean cuándo van a desarrollar un móvil
una aplicación cómo lo hacen y en estas
entrevistas me di cuenta que para ellos
la relación con la data es permanente es
armónica no es investigo primero tengo
la información después me olvido creo la
idea y la lanzó no la data está
permanentemente conversando con ellos y
ellos la ven como una aliada no
solamente de su trabajo sino de su
imaginación la data los hace pensar en
preguntas que no se hubiesen hecho si no
hubiesen visto esa información nuestra
data esto no quiere decir que todo es
absolutamente cuantificable
hay una parte creativa y una parte
artística que necesita de la intuición
que necesita de esa parte un poco más
incluso espiritual que todos tenemos ya
decía picasso o al menos se le atribuye
una frase que dice que los ordenadores
son inútiles porque eso
nos dan respuestas
pero fijaros que hay veces que hay datos
que nos pueden sorprender y que en un
momento determinado incluso no sabemos
qué hacer con ellos hace poco
investigando me enteré que los
millennials están cada vez más viendo
vídeos sobre cómo vivir en una van en
una camioneta
qué puede significar esto
quieren vivir en una avant bueno es un
dato está ahí me sorprende estoy de
acuerdo no estoy de acuerdo no importa
esa data llega y yo puedo ver qué hago
con ella y eso es un poco la invitación
y dan ariely que es un profesor como
sabéis de teoría del comportamiento dice
que este mundo de big data es como el
romance entre los adolescentes nadie lo
está haciendo nadie sabe cómo hacerlo y
todos piensan que los demás si lo están
haciendo entonces el segundo principio
tiene que ver con ver a la data como una
aliada de la imaginación y el tercero
tiene que ver con el error o con el
horror
el error el error como amigo y como
fuente de la creatividad este
aprendizaje tiene que ver con el foco de
esta charla de vernos a cada uno de
nosotros como una startup porque porque
si hay algo fundamental en la mentalidad
de emprendimiento es el valor de
equivocarse el valor de equivocarse
pronto con bajo coste y controlado
esto es un principio básico sin embargo
muchas veces y durante nuestra historia
hemos estado entrenados a temerle al
error y cuando nos equivocamos lo
disimulamos o lo ocultamos nos sentimos
como fracasos accidentales e
incontrolables esos son los errores
sin embargo dentro de esta mentalidad
del emprendimiento el error se ve como
una oportunidad de aprendizaje y se toma
como un aliado se toma como una forma de
aprender y por lo tanto se planea si los
errores se pueden planear yo puedo
establecer a través del concepto de
prototipo y el concepto de piloto cuál
es la relación de mi idea con la
realidad pero no de mi idea ya una vez
perfectamente elaborada sino de mi idea
en su expresión mínima viable pensar en
eso si tenéis una idea cuál es la
expresión mínima viable de esa idea y
cómo la podéis confrontar con la
realidad como la podéis ofrecer
al mundo y que esa idea pueda nutrirse
equivocarse y por lo tanto aprender
esto forma parte de un paradigma muy
interesante que ha promulgado lo que ha
promulgado eric with the link start-up
en donde él propone a las startups en
vez de pasar todo un periodo de
incubación silencioso y luego hacer
todas en el gran lanzamiento él propone
hacer procesos de iteración en donde se
construye la idea se mide se aprende y
seguimos integrando y seguimos dando
vueltas sobre esa idea hasta que la idea
de alguna manera se perfecciona y ahí el
error se hace un amigo no es una amenaza
y dice jonathan rasgos son autor de un
libro muy interesante que se llama el
samurai ágil si la realidad no va con
tus planes
cambia tu plan no cambias la realidad
y el tercer principio entonces y último
es
el error como fuente de creatividad
y ahora cuántos quiero saber cuántos os
sentís un poquito más animados a
emprender alguna idea oa probar algo
nuevo un poco más veo un poco más de
manos eso está bien
recapituló los tres principios aceptar y
disfrutar el no saber y recuperar el
asombro
entender que la data es fuente de
imaginación y también entender que el
error es fuente de creatividad y os
deseo mucho éxito con vuestra startup
personal
[Aplausos]